if Megan was listened to this like three
years ago what you'd be really
interested in is like how you can get
more out of your your time yeah I think
a big thing of that is like managing
your time there's just not enough hours
in the day to do what I want to do but I
have to be realistic I set myself goals
whether that's like really break it down
is quarterly monthly weekly daily so now
I come in and I'm not trying to do like
a hundred things I'm doing 10 things but
I'm doing them really well like it's
things that are going to take you a step
further to the year goal I've learned a
lot more to break that down and learn
that well enough where I can help my
team do that as well